the world's best guides to non-fiction
books come from our sponsor short form
short form offers comprehensive coverage
to thousands of top non-fiction books so
you can learn more faster unlike other
summary Services their guides provide
valuable insights counter arguments and
analyzes for a well-rounded
understanding of the topic try it free
and get 25 off using my link below
CNN is in shambles and has fired its
much celebrated new CEO Chris Licht
after only a year attempting to fix CNN
but dramatically damaging it in the
process this is a major media story in
the United States whatever your media
diet consists of this actually is a
story that will have sort of cascading
impact all across the media ecosystem so
let's discuss it it was indeed a short
Reign for Chris Licht we were told he's
going to come in he's going to fix CNN
which has become apparently two
left-wing and make it more appealing to
all sides of the political Spectrum the
Associated Press reporting
CNN ousts CEO Chris Licht after a brief
tumultuous tenure the chief executive
pushed out of a job Wednesday faced
mounting problems in his first year
leading the struggling Network
viewership and profits were declining
very important aspect to evaluating his
job by CNN programming blunders were
growing and the Network's journalists
were losing confidence by the day Chris
licht's very bad year culminated in a
damning magazine profile last week it's
in the Atlantic I recommend you check it
out it's quite interesting and just a
few days later his tumultuous 13-month
tenure is over 51 year old Licht was
informed of his ouster Wednesday morning
and it was announced to the staff at the
daily editorial meeting the same place
were licked two days earlier said he
would quote fight like hell to earn the
trust of those around him the executive
who hired and fired lick that's David
saslav the CEO of CNN parent company
Warner Brothers Discovery accepted some
of the blame for the turmoil over the
last year and has appointed a
four-person interim leadership team
zazlev promised CNN staff a thorough
search for licht's replacement here's
the announcement happening on CNN
we have news now to report involving our
own network news to us here at CNN and
you at home CNN's chairman and CEO Chris
Licht is leaving the network right took
over the network a little over a year
ago David zazlov the chairman of CNN's
parent company Warner Brothers Discovery
he just made the announcement at the
network editorial meeting for now a
leadership team will take click's place
led by Amy and tell us who's the
Executive Vice President of talent and
content development along with Virginia
Mosley the EVP of editorial Eric
shirling our programming EVP and David
Levy our new Chief Operating Officer
right Sarah very very exciting stuff so
here's the story
a number of reasons for this firing and
they all make sense plummeting ratings I
mean okay at the end of the day this is
a for-profit media Outlet ratings were a
disaster journalistic blunders internal
strife all of it but one of the most
important aspects of this is that the
staff at CNN obviously lost confidence
in this guy the audience has been
increasingly confused about what on
Earth is happening at CNN and the brand
has been embarrassed and it is a brand
that for a very long time I mean listen
I don't take pleasure in this I'm going
to give you my analysis in a moment but
I remember being a kid and seeing on CNN
important moments you know when I think
back to the early 90s and the mid 90s I
remember the first Iraq War
I remember
um the assassination of Israeli Prime
Minister Rabin
I remember the Clinton impeachment and
Monica Lewinsky situation in the mid 90s
all of it was brought by CNN this is
pre-fox news even existing and there was
a certain gravitas when it comes to what
CNN did and maybe still does best I
don't know uh which is those types of
events licht's biggest mistake was that
he misread the mood of the country and
the media landscape and instead of
saying oh we need to bring CNN back to
primarily being that thing which I
remember from when I was a kid it was
the Assumption from lick that CNN lost
viewers because it had become too
liberal and anti-trump and the solution
I guess that Chris Licht thought was
appropriate was let's show both sides
let's Court Republicans let's bring on
more Republican strategists and former
Trump staffers and others and do this
Trump Town Hall which was I mean
arguably there was no way that was going
to go well and Licht did that
ignoring that CNN's core audience wasn't
aching for right-wing nuttery it just
there was not actually a demand for
right-wing nuttery from the audience
Licht also underestimated the
competition from Fox and MSNBC in the
sense of the more ideologically based
cable news networks Fox News carving out
a right-wing editorial position
MSNBC carving out a center-left sort of
Democratic party establishment position
and so the idea that CNN is just going
to bring in some Trump people and then
all of a sudden we're going to have an
ideological platform that will attract
viewers it simply wasn't happening and
this led to a whole bunch of different
fiascos that damaged CNN's credibility
and its Integrity yes the Trump Town
Hall widely criticized as a softball
platform for Trump even though in her
defense anchor Caitlyn Collins did do
some of what was possible to do but it's
such a fire hose of misinformation from
Trump
and the environment was not right with a
crowd full of trump sycophants
titillated in the audience it just
didn't go well and in one sense it was a
ratings flop in another sense it was
journalistically problematic and
immediately people started calling for
Lick's resignation so I do think this
was necessary and it was obvious only to
stop the bleeding there is no guarantee
it's not enough CNN still has to figure
out how do we deal with the challenges
and the uncertainties the post-trump era
although it might again become a trump
era what's the vision that CNN might
articulate I don't know what the answer
is if I were CNN
and I know nothing about cable news
programming or any of it I would invest
in quality journalism diverse voices and
I don't mean diversity in the sense of
make sure you've got an Asian woman and
a black guy I'm not talking about that
type of diversity I mean diversity in
terms of types of Journalism and
Innovative formats one of the best
things CNN ever did quite frankly and
this is very much a departure from what
CNN used to be known for was bring
Anthony Bourdain's program to CNN and
Anthony Bourdain's life tragically
ending of course but figure out what's
the unique value proposition just being
like well we we've become known as an
anti-trump voice let's bring on some
right Wingers it's it's just it's vapid
it's not going to work
um no desire to see CNN fail and in fact
although I'm critical of the entire
apparatus of for-profit 24-hour cable
news
for all the reasons many of you know
when you have to fill 24 hours you do
low effort stuff and then the quality
degrades yeah I've talked about all
these things but I don't want there to
only be two major cable news networks I
think more is better as a general rule
so shambles at CNN let's now talk about
Mike Pence a former vice president Mike
Pence has officially launched his 2024
presidential campaign we're going to
look at two events that he did yesterday
the announcement speech as well as the
CNN Town Hall
I don't know which went worse they both
went very poorly let's start with the
speech in Iowa at which Mike Pence
announced he is indeed running for
president
he is now trying to frame himself as the
Patriot when it comes to the January 6th
Trump riots will the Republican
electorate go for this
I don't know
January 6 was a tragic day in the life
of our nation wow but thanks to the
courage of law enforcement
the violence was quelled
and we reconvened the Congress the very
same day
to complete the work
of the American people under the
Constitution of the United States okay
as I've said many times
on that fateful day
president Trump's words were Reckless
they endangered my family and everyone
at the Capitol
but the American people deserve to know
that on that day president Trump also
demanded
that I choose between him
and the Constitution
and he chose the Constitution
now voters will be faced with the same
choice
I chose the Constitution
and I always will
all right so not exactly riveting stuff
from Mike Pence but he has very little
it's sort of like why are you running
again if people want a pro-trump
trump-affiliated voice they'll go with
Trump and if they want something else
they'll go with someone who wasn't
Trump's VP the idea that anyone is going
to go for Pence is completely and
totally laughable we'll get to the
polling in a moment here is Mike Pence
comparing President Biden and uh Donald
Trump which was an interesting moment
for sure most Americans treat each other
with kindness and respect even when we
disagree
we know how to be good neighbors
that's not too much to ask our leaders
to do the same
but sadly it's clear that neither Joe
Biden or Donald Trump share this belief
I don't think that's true even remotely
in fact if there's a stronger criticism
of Biden is he's treating too
respectfully a republican opposition
that operates exclusively in bad faith
and he shouldn't even bother with them
that's the real criticism of Biden
and neither of them intend to even try
to bring our country together
but I believe it's not just about
civility
to craft real solutions
all right you get it anyway saying
neither Biden or Trump have the respect
that Pence would bring to the race
although it's hard to really believe
that Mike Pence like other Republicans
have tried including Trump taking credit
for the end of Roe v Wade which I don't
know if is a great strategy given that
Roe v Wade was quite popular with the
American people and maybe
maybe most important of all
it was our Administration that appointed
three of the justices that sent Roe
versus Wade to the ash heap of History
where it belonged right
[Applause]
we gave America A New Beginning for life
you know when Donald Trump ran for
president in 2016 he promised to govern
as a conservative
together we did just that
so then why not vote for Trump so anyway
I don't know how popular bragging about
being responsible for the elimination of
Roe v Wade I don't know how good of a
strategy that is it's not clear how
popular that even is among Republican
primary voters never mind Republican
voters overall but this is the approach
Pence is taking and understand that he
has very little else to go on or to run
on he was later interviewed on Fox News
after his big announcement speech and
just almost two minutes of complete and
total nonsense just it's hard to imagine
how this would Inspire even a single
Republican voter today it's Sandra here
most people want to know if they're
considering voting voting for you in the
primary if if they think that you can
win and you've jumped into a field with
your former boss Donald Trump and they
are likely wondering how you plan to run
against Donald Trump not well
well you know we really laid out that
choice today but uh but honestly by the
way who's this we the reason we started
here in Iowa is because uh Karen and I
are going to spend an awful lot of time
in Iowa this fall and in New Hampshire
and in South Carolina you know one of
the things that I've come to realize the
last few years is that I'm I'm I'm I'm
well known but I'm not known well I
think people know me more as a uh as a
as a quiet vice president standing off
the president's shoulder loyally
supporting him all the way until a day
when my oath to the Constitution
required me to do otherwise but now we
have an opportunity with all the great
people in this state to travel to the
cities and the farms and and the byways
and the highways and let people really
get to know the penses not just my years
so the question was how are you going to
defeat Trump I'm not hearing an answer
this is vice president but when I I led
the state of Indiana through tax cuts
expanded educational Choice stood for
the right to life and of course as you
all know me from years ago when I I was
a leader of house conservatives I I
bucked The Big Spenders in in my own
party imagine thinking that lines like I
bucked The Big Spenders are going to get
you ahead of Donald Trump in a
completely delusional Republican primary
so a quick look at the polls where they
stand right now Mike Pence currently
polling 3.8 percent and you've got to
give him credit he's already ahead of
Vivek ramaswamy he's more than doubling
the polling support of Tim Scott he's
well ahead of Chris Christie polling one
percent at last check but I do not see
any path towards the nomination for
Pence after the break we'll look at
Pence's CNN Town Hall if you thought his
speech lacked energy just wait until you
see this delusional CNN Town Hall after
this short break
one of our sponsors is short form short
form makes the world's best guides to
non-fiction books and not only does
short form Summarize each non-fiction
book itself into key points that you can
cover in just a few minutes they have
all sorts of interactive exercises to
help you apply the ideas to what you've
read to retain more the guide to each
book also includes intellectual insights
comparing and contrasting the book to
other prominent books about the same
topic so that you can contextualize the
book and understand the controversies
and the disagreements they also have
books across every non-fiction genre
from economics and politics to science
and health I was recently checking out
James clear's Atomic habits on short
form of course they have the guide but
they also have highlights they also
include other similar books about habits
and developing a routine with
differences and similarities super super
useful and a lot more than just a summer
of the book there are new guides and
articles released every week and short
form is giving my audience a free trial
plus 25 off a subscription which is a
fifty dollar value so for the price of a
book per month you get access to
thousands go to shortform.com packman
the link is down below if you thought
Mike Pence's campaign announcement in
Iowa yesterday was bad just wait until
you get a look at a CNN Town Hall which
was hosted by Dana Bash you know one of
the things that is very interesting to
see with these modern right-wingers is
how quickly their talking points fall
apart not when presented with opposition
per se from the other side but simply
when there is any follow-up and Dana
Bash as you will see during some of
these clips provides just really simple
questions that Mike Pence at some point
doesn't even know how to respond to now
to his credit I will say Pence is
starting to draw some distinction with
Donald Trump and you you've got to do
that if you you're going to justify
people voting for you instead of trump
when you served under Trump why would
they go for the number two if they like
the number one when number one is
running okay you understand that here is
Pence saying
Trump thinks Putin's a genius
I think Putin is a war criminal all
right at least it's a distinction
Donald Trump said in his CNN Town Hall
he was asked whether he wanted Ukraine
to win the war
and he would not say what message does
that send to Vladimir Putin
well and frankly When Vladimir Putin
rolled into Ukraine
the former president called him a genius
oh
I know the difference between a genius
and a war criminal right and I know who
needs to win in the war in Ukraine and
it's the people fighting for their
freedom and fighting to restore their
National sovereignty in Ukraine and
America it's not our war
but freedom is our fight
and we need to give the people of
Ukraine the ability to fight and defend
their food even the Applause is milk
toast like it's not just the answers
nobody seems to eat in any way inspired
by this but listen to Pence's credit
there are other people running in this
Republican primary who aren't even
willing to say that so credit where
credit is due even if it's for
pathetically small things now here was a
really interesting moment Dana Bash
seemed to visibly stump Mike Pence
when she pointed out you know deterrent
claiming that the death penalty for
shootings will be a deterrent doesn't
make sense when many of the mass
Shooters want to be killed and Pence was
visibly stumped by this a very
interesting moment quickly go back to
something you said about
processing people who engage in mass
shootings a lot of people who are mass
Shooters they go in with the intention
to die right so how would the threat of
execution be a deterrent
well I
I follow these stories just as closely
as you do
and of course our years in the white
house we saw one tragedy after another
and and I know we hear that and we we
see evidence oftentimes in the aftermath
that they went in without regard
whether they would survive right
but I I just believe in the deterrent
of the law ah and I believe perhaps if
if we made it clear I mean think about
this the Parkland shooter is going to
spend the rest of his life in jail true
in Florida
and that's not Justice okay
he believes in the deterrent of law
but that passing stricter gun laws
wouldn't make a difference how is that
possible the death penalty would be a
deterrent even though as Dana Bash
correctly points out many of these
shooters plan to die they want to die
sometimes they take their own lives if
they aren't taken by by First Responders
so that's going to be a deterrent
but stricter gun laws won't be a
deterrent that doesn't really make any
sense it says incoherent as many of
these modern Republican positions Mike
Pence talked falsely
about how Democrats want abortion on
demand until the moment of birth which
of course isn't true when Dana Bash
points that out the Democrat party's
position is abortion On Demand with
taxpayer dollars all the way up to the
moment of birth says who and as we talk
about the possibility of uh national
standards say a 15-week standard which
would put America more in line with most
of the European Union
most of the European countries have
either a 12 to 15 week rule on abortion
our laws today are more in line with
China Iran and North Korea
and for my part if I have the great
privilege to serve as president of the
United States I'll I'll support the
cause of Life at every level
the state level the local level with
taxpayer dollars and at the national
level and just the person you're running
against or you want to run against if
you get the nomination is President
Biden he says that codifying Roe versus
Wade is his position that means a right
to an abortion until the point of
viability not up until uh until birth
but and and Mike Pence smirking at being
told the truth about the widespread
position from Joe Biden on that issue on
the question of Trump's crimes Penn
seems to be going with yes Trump
committed crimes and attempted to
violate the constitution but we kind of
should just move on with no consequences
I think now more than ever we ought to
be fine in ways we could actually come
together and this kind of this kind of
action by the Department of Justice I
think would only fuel
further division in the country let me
also say
I think it would also send a terrible
message to The Wider world
I mean we're the we're the emblem of
democracy we're the symbol of Justice
indeed really the serious matter which
has already happened once in New York of
indicting a former president of the
United States sends a terrible message
to the world I hope the doj thinks
better of it and resolves these issues
without an indictment sir I just want to
clarify what you're saying is that if
they believe he committed a crime they
should not go forward with an indictment
you just talked before about no by the
way anybody else noticing how Pence does
this weird thing where while Dana Bash
is talking to him he doesn't look at her
he just looks out into the middle
distance it's a very strange thing and
Pence does this to a lot of people
getting to the rule
clear that no one's Above the Law okay
but with regard to the unique
circumstances here
no one's above the law but but but but
okay just a couple more of these uh Penn
says that he has no interest in
pardoning the individuals convicted for
rioting on January 6th the Constitution
of the United States sir on that Donald
Trump says he is quote inclined to
Pardon many members of the mob who
attacked the capitol on January 6. those
people were of course part of the same
mob who built Gallows and chanted about
wanting to hang you right would you
consider partying and pardoning any of
them
you know on the day of January 6 I
issued a tweet
demanding that people leave the capitol
folks he tweeted and end the violence
and I said that those that failed to do
that should be prosecuted to the fullest
extent of the law right
and I continue to believe that today
we cannot ever allow what happened on
January 6 to happen again in the heart
of our democracy what about the people
stand by the decisions and the due
process of court in our laws and uh I I
have no interest or no intention
partnering those that that assaulted
police officers will vandalized our
Capital all right now understand that
even there he's saying he has no
interest in pardoning those who
assaulted police officers or vandalized
the capital but if there are people who
were charged for other things he doesn't
seem to be ruling that out although with
Pence you never really know what he
means with his slippery language and
then lastly Pence refusing to rule out
pardoning Donald Trump if he were to be
elected president
[Applause]
of a crime
and your elected president would you
pardon him
well I I don't want to speak about
hypotheticals oh
I'm not sure I'm going to be elected
president of the United States I'm sure
that you're not but okay
Dana I'm going to decline to answer that
on the basis that I have absolutely no
path to the nomination whatsoever and I
don't even know why I'm really here so
on that basis I'm going to decline to
answer that question
but I believe we have a fighting chance
I really believe we do and if you are
and I I would hope again Dana you're
you're as uh persistent as ever
CNN is living up to its reputation
and look there are real issues the
American people are facing and rather
than talking about that I want to talk
about what so he doesn't want to answer
that question so a disastrous campaign
launch for Mike Pence no path to the
nomination but could he end up helping
Trump in Trump's path to the Republican
nomination we'll talk about that maybe
tomorrow maybe on Monday
televangelist Christian demagogue Pat
Robertson has passed away at the age of
93. the Associated Press reporting Pat
Robertson broadcaster who helped make
religion Central to Republican politics
dies at 93 a man we have covered for a
very very long time founder of the
Christian Broadcasting Network the 700
Club for more than half a century he was
known for his 700 Club television show
now as I said when Rush Limbaugh passed
away and as I said when we've seen the
deaths of many different figures I don't
wish death upon anyone these individuals
to the extent that they have family and
friends and loved ones they are loved
they are missed people are grieving and
that is their absolute right and
privilege and also I can recognize that
in their public life they were
extraordinarily damaging to the country
and to the world and Pat Robertson was
one of the most damaging religious
influences in America of the last 50
years part of the movement that stuffed
and stuffed and stuffed religiosity into
uh civil government and the Republican
Party wanted a Christian version of
sharia law
this is the reality one little highlight
for you here is
um Pat Robertson at the uh in the
earlier phases of when the country was
going in the direction of saying Hey
listen like gay marriage not a big deal
etc
apocalyptically stating that it will
bring the Judgment of God on the nation
and we will be vomited out by the land
if uh the equality act passes let them
know that you are opposed to what is
called a
of course it's it's got a name and all
they always give the good names to these
things this is a devastating blow to
religious freedom and to the sanctity of
America if you want to bring the
Judgment of God on This Nation you just
keep this stuff up you know I was
reading in Leviticus where it said
because of these things the land will
vomit you out right vomit you out I
think God will say I've had it with
America if you do this kind of stuff I
want to get rid of you as a nation and
you know there's plenty of stuff that's
going on uh when you look at this so
super scary stuff you will get vomited
out I do want to remind everybody there
is a very long list of things that Pat
Robertson during his storied career said
are demonic or potentially demonic
remember that demons can attach
themselves this is from Pat Robertson I
can't play all of these clips but you
can find them in our archives secondhand
sweaters can have demonic attachment we
Ouija boards yoga Harry Potter feng shui
karate
horoscopes the Twilight series paintings
of Buddha
TV shows about ghosts can be demonic
Halloween absolutely demonic psychics
can be demonic when young girls levitate
their friends at sleepovers that can be
demonic and sometimes adopted children
from other countries can be demonic
according to Pat Robertson we also had
this absolutely classic classic moment
where Pat Robertson said even little
babies just out of the womb could
conceivably be demonic as well remember
this amen all right here's the caller
Lisa from Fallen Nevada
my question is regarding
the 10 babies do possessed and if so
does the age of accountability come into
play for salvation right
um I I you asked about things can babies
be possessed and if so does the age of
accountability come into play for
salvation well the age of accountability
has to do at the point you know what
we're right from wrong and that normally
doesn't take in place to your old enough
to understand something's wrong so the
age of accountability can be five it can
be six it could be four it could be
three but can a baby be demon possessed
I I just believe if if
that child is born to a family of devil
worshipers there's a real possibility
that the the the the devil will think
that he has a claim over that child I
mean it's horrible to contemplate but we
you know I don't think that there he
doesn't take pleasure in giving us this
news but yeah babies can come out of the
womb demon possessed so 93 year old Pat
Robertson passing away
uh an incredible Legacy which I think is
a negative one
uh and we will leave it there we will
take a quick break and be back right
after this
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
today we're going to be speaking with
Steve Schmidt who's a renowned American
political strategist formerly of the
2008 McCain campaign and many other
campaigns founder of the warning a
newsletter podcast and YouTube channel
as well Steve great to have you on I
appreciate your time
good to be with you my pleasure so where
are you on the Republican party at this
point in time I'm I'm curious because
your views have certainly evolved over
time I mean our audience made may or may
not know about them
well I founded the Lincoln project in
2020 to oppose Donald Trump I was uh
Arnold Schwarzenegger's campaign manager
I was a top strategist for George W bush
I served in the bush white house but I
have always recognized that Donald Trump
was a profound threat to the Republic
along with every other person in the
Republican Party the difference is uh a
few of us when we said never meant it uh
and overwhelmingly as in 99.99
of every person involved in the
institutional Republican party allowed
themselves to capitulate appease what I
regard as the most dangerous threat that
the country has faced uh internally
since the Civil War and what I viewed
Republican party as as a in a two-party
system in this country is a profound
threat that has been hijacked by a
faction that has turned against
fundamental American Concepts such as
democracy and pluralism and all of it uh
is is deeply ground in walking away from
the results of an election and I just
last thing I'll say about that I'm the
person who placed the phone call for
John McCain to Barack Obama
um and uh you know I was the first
Republican in America to say the words
congratulations Mr president-elect
before I handed the phone to them and so
this is Elemental in a free society and
that's what the parties walked away from
so as far as policy goes I mean are you
still like a low tax guy you want to
reduce abortion or have your views also
changed over time I was a moderate
republican from New Jersey right so the
northeastern tradition of republicanism
was not ideological it wasn't Southern
it wasn't Evangelical the Republican
Party in the northeastern states was a
Reform Party and it typically took power
after the excesses of the machine run
party controlled Democrats of those
States so you always had
non-ideological Republicans Jacob Javits
Christy Whitman Tom Kane in New Jersey
that ran on records of of
environmentalism I've always
supported a woman's right to choose and
I was one of the very earliest people
um with any profile in the country to
come out in favor of gay marriage in the
Republican party I I worked for the ACLU
leading the marriage equality campaigns
I don't think that you can look
seriously into account camera as a
Republican and say hey this is a
fiscally conservative party there is no
fiscally conservative party in America
you have two wildly spending political
parties that have accumulated 32
trillion dollars in national debt
um if you look at the baby boomer
presidencies Bill Clinton was the most
fiscally responsible Barack Obama was
number two George Bush was number three
and Donald Trump was the wildest spender
of them all when it cut you mentioned
New Jersey you know when I look at the
Republican primary field now as a guy
from the progressive left it seems so
obvious to me that Chris Christie is by
far the most competent and qualified
person running in that primary and if
you said to me David the next president
will be someone currently running in the
Republican primary it would be so
obvious to me that Chris Christie would
be my choice he's polling one percent
okay we don't yet have polling from
after his announcement what is your
sense of whether there is any desire
among the current Republican party for
someone like a Chris Christie
well I look I think it is a mistake for
people to look at Chris Christie and
just to Lively say he has no chance
reality is
in order to win the Republican
nomination
you have to win somewhere first
so when you look at this right now
could Tim Scott win in Iowa Tim Scott
can win in Iowa
I think he's the only person who can
beat Trump in Iowa who's in the field
right now can Chris Christie win in New
Hampshire is it possible if if you look
at Chris Christie's Town Hall from the
other night and you look for example at
Tim Ryan's Town Hall that he did on Fox
News and he basically said many of the
same things that Chris Christie did you
watch that fox audience and people's
faces are contorted and twisted in Anger
as he's telling them right that Trump
lost the election you got the guy with
the Maga hat no we saw the Trump town
hall on CNN when people are cheering
because Trump had just been found guilty
of sexual abuse and defamation right you
didn't see any of that in that audience
in New Hampshire right of people who
turned out to Chris Christie right you
if you watch that closely on a body
language perspective
those people are not rejecting what he's
saying so now however it is that that
Chris got there right over seven long
years and I'm gonna I'm gonna step I'm
gonna I'm just gonna skip that whole
part of it because I I think it's
tedious we all we all know his record
his Stepford Wife appearance but he's
the only person in the race
such as it is who's just telling the
truth right now now he hasn't always
been truthful on these issues to say to
say the least but right in the race
right now he's our guy he's your guy
he's my guy because he's the only guy
who's saying things that heretofore no
one has said to these audiences any
person who's who's running uh have lived
in a delusion sphere and good for Chris
Christie better late than never is a
saying for a reason you know that he's
bringing up the Manifest corruption and
all the other all the other issues is he
flawed of course he is flawed but you
know it's he's the best that they got
right now and there is a truth teller in
the race and and that hasn't been the
case the only group that that has ever
confronted him effectively is the group
that I started it it indisputably drew
blood in the in the sixth year of
Trump's presence on the national stage
so I hope Chris Christie can do that in
terms of the other non-trump people that
are running we've seen pretty
significant hesitation to really go
after Trump Christy and his town hall
was direct and he said the path to the
nomination is through Trump and Trump's
going to try to go through me I'm going
to try to go through him with everybody
else you know Nikki Haley early on would
basically just chalk it up to I'm a
woman and I'm younger and I'm a person
of color and Tim Scott when he was given
the opportunity to really draw
distinctions with Trump sort of said the
contrast is going to be clear and what
exactly he meant by that I don't know
what what he meant DeSantis is starting
to criticize Trump a little but it seems
that there's this idea that if they are
there
and then Trump gets arrested three more
times and maybe it pulls him off the
campaign Trail they will be able to
swoop in and somehow pick up Trump
supporters by virtue of not having
really attacked Trump at this early
stage is that viable and number two if
it is it can't be viable for all of them
it seems maybe for one of them that
would work
it's it's not viable for any of them
look at the end of the day it's a
position that's rooted in a fundamental
delusional dishonesty and if you look at
what a presidential contest is
the race for the presidency in the
United States is the greatest
non-lethal competition in the world
there's nothing there is nothing like it
there there is no game there is no sport
there is nothing that is as intense as
focused as this and so what this is as
David Axelrod once said is an MRI for
the soul right this is a character test
and so each of these people right put
aside their beliefs their ideology their
political label they're weak and they're
afraid they're terrified of being
tweeted about by Donald Trump Mike
Pence's race has no rationale whatsoever
his former boss the president tried to
have him hung and and he just now will
only say well he endangered me and
others and my family yeah the the
American people in in our full range of
our vast Menagerie right of beliefs in
everything else
from left to right
the American people will not vote for
weaklings will not vote for
spinelessness right so so every one of
these people and exclusively right
they're all the people that played a
previous role as Trump sycophants who
won't tell the truth about him now what
they what they prove is their softness
it is disqualifying so all of these
people whether it's the North Dakota
governor who could let's say right and
I've never seen the guy I couldn't pick
him out of a lineup I don't know if he's
good or not he can talk or not but but
could there be a reform-minded governor
from a small state in the tradition of a
Jimmy Carter in 1976 is there space for
that in the Republican party there is
but you asked the North Dakota governor
right well what about his claims about
the stolen election right what about him
saying this ah you won't say a word it's
like he's in the witness protection Pro
program right you know he's like facing
down Pablo Escobar a trial he won't NADA
right right and it's disqualifying when
it comes to the economy there's been
this idea for a long time in American
politics that when you look at a
re-election of a sitting president so
much of it is Guided by the state of the
economy however there's this strange
thing happening right now
where on Monday I looked at every
indicator that's usually used how has
the stock market been doing what's the
unemployment rate job creation numbers
GDP inflation trade balance right we
look at all of it it all looks pretty
okay unremarkable or like pretty good
and yet all the time on my YouTube
channel I see comments from people
saying you're you're worried because the
economy is a disaster Biden has failed
on the economy and when I say well show
me a metric that proves that people will
write to me they'll say well if you
compare wages to housing costs we're
looking pretty deep here to find
something that would point to an economy
that's not at minimum okay if not
cruising along pretty pretty well what's
your view on this issue maybe not so
much about the the state of the economy
but the disconnect about even if the
metrics look fine the story is still
that the economy is terrible what I
would say what I would say about that is
what you're talking about is the
difference between emotion and
rationality right and so the so the
question you're asking is a question
about a feeling right not a not a
question about the weather right so you
go outside it's 85 degrees and sunny and
someone says this is a terrible day you
look at them and you say it's obviously
not it's a beautiful day right but but
but this is much more subjective right
so first off
um and you look at some of the ratings
decline on cable for example cable news
um it makes perfect sense I mean 80
percent of the people that appear on CNN
for example on any given day are
appearing from Washington D.C and almost
none of those people make under a couple
of million dollars a year so so they are
in a place that is detached from reality
they live in a rarified air and there is
a lack of appreciation across the board
for the fact that 40 percent of the
country doesn't have 400 cash available
that enormous percentages of the
e123e4 ranks in the military deal with
food insecurity issues
um go look at the payday lending outside
of a military base does any normal
person have access to a return on the
stock market in the sense of here's a
stock this company has a value it's
going to grow this is all computer
trading against algorithms at the edge
of a moment of profound disruption
caused by technology
globalization and there's a lack of an
animating Vision
um that communicates to people what's
what's going to happen next so I think
that all of Biden's deficiencies
um in in a political sense are rooted in
a in an awful failure of communications
and and that is and that is where that
is very very worrying right if you're if
you're a football team you have to throw
the ball if you're the president of the
United States running for re-election in
a fraud time against a massive massive
massive massive misinformation
propaganda Network all of it put
together you have to communicate like
Tom Brady throws at football and and
even the most generous generous fan of
the of the president has to understand
has to appreciate that that there is a
massive communication deficit in the in
the evidence of that is that this
radical extremist anti-American movement
has not been crushed politically it's
still alive and it's still in a position
to take power in this next election has
to be the place where it's put away for
good we've been speaking with political
strategist Steve Schmidt he is the
founder of the warning and we will link
to the newsletter podcast and YouTube
channel Steve really appreciate your
time and insights today
my pleasure to be with you
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show the last
24 hours have seen both reports that
Trump is imminently going to get
indicted and subsequently arrested by
the justice department federal charges
and the last 24 hours saw denials from
Donald Trump even when some of these
reports came from Trump's own social
media site truth social essential let's
discuss a um an article on just the news
which is sort of a wacky right website
feds inform Trump he is Target likely to
be indicted as doj rebuffs prosecutorial
misconduct claim Trump defense has
submitted secret evidence alleging a
prosecutor tried to sway witness
testimony by discussing Federal
judgeship also published to truth social
this message breaking feds inform Trump
of imminent indictment by special
counsel Jack Smith however Trump denying
the report from his own website posting
quote no one has told me I'm being
indicted and I shouldn't be because I've
done nothing wrong but I have assumed
for years that I am a capital T Target
of the weaponized doj and FBI starting
with the russia-russia Russia Hoak the
no collusion Mueller report impeachment
hoax number one
impeachment hoax number two the perfect
Ukraine phone call and various other
scams and witch hunts a travesty of
justice and election interference at a
level never seen before republicans in
Congress must make this their number one
issue so is it true that Trump is
imminently going to be indicted and
arrested federally and charged these
would be the second charges against
Trump we may then see additional federal
charges we may then see charges at the
state level out of Georgia sometime
between July and September or is it all
wrong my bottom line on this is that it
does increasingly seem like yes Donald
Trump is going to be indicted federally
however he may not have been informed of
it over the last 24 to 48 hours the way
that just the news reported uh other
reports claim that maybe by the end of
tomorrow the doj will be requesting
those indictments from the grand jury
that is reconvened it's just important
to remember
when the indictments are asked for to
the grand jury
and then when the grand jury votes
potentially yes to do the indictments
and then when the indictment actually
happens these are three different things
and so like with many of these news
events that are quickly taking shape and
changing and whatever the case may be
you have to remember that sometimes
people are just confused about which
step of the process they're referring to
but at this point my guess my prediction
and I'm not in the prediction game but
my prediction if you don't make me Bet
On It is that yes Donald Trump is going
to be indicted federally and it seemed
to send him into an absolute and total
panic let's talk about that next at
midnight last night
failed former president twice impeached
and once arrested Donald Trump
seem to have a textual panic attack on
Troth Central over what appears to be at
this time an inevitable forthcoming
indictment and arrest federally
federally these are the all capital
letters posts of a panicked madman who
is scared and maybe realizing that his
time is running out Trump posting at
midnight last night quote shocking one
of the top prosecutors at the department
of Injustice was reportedly so obsessed
with getting Trump that he tried to
bribe and intimidate a lawyer
representing someone being targeted and
harassed to falsely accuse and fabricate
a story about President Donald J Trump a
crime that doesn't exist this criminal
and salacious act from within the doj
has brought criminal and salacious I'm
sorry has brought shame and
embarrassment to this once great and
respected institution I struggle so
badly to read these Trump rants because
of this there is now extreme turmoil
inside the doj unclear that that's true
Trump continuing on post too and
labeling it page two a top over zealous
and dishonest doj prosecutor offered a
Witnesses lawyer an important judgeship
in the Biden Administration if his
client flips on President Trump
who has done nothing wrong the highly
respected lawyer was incensed and
disgusted at the corrupt and illegal
offer the fake case against me must be
immediately dropped and the Inspector
General should launch an investigation
into this and the many other all too
obvious wrongdoings and crimes taking
place at the doj and FBI it's very
difficult to find anything that is true
here we do not have any evidence of
alleged crimes committed by the doj and
FBI we have no evidence at this time
that there is overzealous prosecution of
Donald Trump in fact the truth is the
opposite the concern has been and the
Rumblings have pointed to even with
evidence against Trump of trump
criminality
it doesn't seem clear that there's a
willingness by the Department of Justice
to actually indict a former president we
now are starting to believe that that's
not true and that the doj is going to go
forward and indict Trump but there is
essentially nothing real here but you
have to understand that this is the
court of public opinion and the Maga the
magats or the magedonians or whatever
they're being called at this point in
time
they accept this stuff like it's being
spoon fed to them they they uncritically
accept it period end of story and so
much of this could be working to
activate voters either for the
Republican primary or the eventual
general election in November of 24 there
are all sorts of other reasons why Trump
would be doing this including that the
guy is just panicking and scared because
he's already been indicted and arrested
once and it could happen three more
times we're going to follow it all very
closely by the time this show is out we
may already know more or we may not
until tomorrow or maybe next week we
have a voicemail number that you can
call and leave me a voicemail that
number is 219 to David P here is a
caller Furious that I'm not talking
about alien spaceships take a listen to
this hey Dave Steve in San Diego yes sir
you're a vexing Cosmic conscience
calling in once again to challenge you
on your utter failure to address the
most important story in the history of
the planet which is UFOs are real we
have now totally accredited all the
justification and backing in the world
type guy who has just come out an
official whistleblower saying look that
it is real you have to deal with it stop
playing games okay you might you my
friend are playing games still you
ignore the story you don't want to cover
it you minimized it you've dismissed it
instead let's go yet another segment on
why Donald Trump is bad and how you can
look all Superior and smarmy pointing
that out whether or not Donald Trump is
bad is not the point point is you would
rather cover nonsense than the most
important story ever and the answer must
be you're afraid you're afraid Dave I'm
calling you out why because if UFOs are
real and they are then it calls into
questions and undermines everything that
you're
touting as being so important to cover
that is quite a conspiracy theory now I
think it's really important to mention
when you say UFOs are real all you're
saying is there have been flying objects
that were unidentified
what this caller means and what this
caller is referring to is that
intelligent aliens with spaceships are
real I've acknowledged UFOs are real in
the sense that there have been flying
objects that we did not at least
immediately identify
that is very different than what is now
being said now what is this individual
referring to two days ago
two alleged whistleblowers have come
forward and have said the U.S has in its
possession intact alien Vehicles they
are not from China or Russia we know
that these are from aliens from other
planets we have intact vehicles and it
is being covered up now when you say I'm
scared to cover it what exactly would I
say because these are claims from two
people
they've not been verified by any
independent source and no evidence has
been presented so given that there's no
evidence what exactly could I say now
the conspiracy theorist will say right
but David they're hiding the evidence
the fact remains we have no evidence
the claims of these two people in the
last couple days have been contradicted
by the official report on unidentified
aerial phenomena that the Pentagon
released in 2021 now folks like this
caller will say but that report is part
of the effort to deceive people and to
hide the truth
I don't have evidence of that and that
sort of depends on whether you trust
these two people
or whether you trust the report that was
published what do you prefer to rely
upon either way
uh I don't have evidence to support what
this caller is telling me so it's tough
when people say you're not covering it
you should be covering it you're afraid
to cover it what exactly could I add to
the story
there are unproven claims from one or
maybe two people
for which no evidence has been presented
which some people see and say that's the
cover-up that's the conspiracy I don't
know what you want me to say about it
because not only do I not have evidence
for the claims being made I also don't
have evidence that there is any cover-up
taking place and I know that
conspiracy-minded people say that's the
evidence of the conspiracy absence of
evidence is evidence
but that's not really the type of show
this is we have to deal in empiricism
and reality and evidence so I'm open to
hearing from the audience is this a
story I should be aggressively covering
should I be all over the claims of one
or maybe two people that the U.S has
intact daily and spacecraft absent any
evidence suggesting that that's the case
or is there not very much for me to say
about it let me know what you think and
I will be guided by the audience we are
going to have such a great bonus show
for you today oh the bone
testing Us in making money on today's
bonus show we are going to talk about
another explosive Republican campaign
launch for president the governor of
North Dakota Doug burgum is running I
know I know you've never heard of them
but
he's running okay we'll talk about it
number two the group moms for Liberty
has been designated an extremist group
and Trump's a big fan of the group we
will talk about that and number three by
popular demand we will talk about the
Apple Vision Pro
this has been revealed by Apple
um I have many thoughts we will discuss
them on the bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com don't miss today's bonus
show produced every single weekday for
our members and you can use the coupon
code indicted very relevant coupon code
today to get a discount at
joinpakman.com I'll see you then or
we'll be back here tomorrow for the
Friday show
thank you
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors the world's best
guides to non-fiction books come from
our sponsor short form short form offers
comprehensive coverage to thousands of
top non-fiction books so you can learn
more faster unlike other summary
Services their guides provide valuable
insights counter arguments and analyzes
for a well-rounded understanding of the
topic try it free and get 25 off using
my link below